الحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما
‏in
our
in our
prop صلى الله عليه
قران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
رمضان
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز
انا انزلناه في ليله
القدر
سبحانه وتعالى
قران
ليله القدر
اسلام
القدر
رمضان
الامام احمد رحمه الله
واثله ابن الاسقعه رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه
الله
[Silence]
صحف ابراهيم
تل
ابراهيم
توراه
انجيل
الزبور
داود عليه السلام قران
صحف موسى
صحف موسى ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى
موران
قران
الفرقان
التوراه
صحف موسى
واثله بنسقع
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابراهيم عليه السلام
تو
موسى عليه السلام
رمضان
انجيل
عيسى عليه السلام
رمضان
داود عليه
‏was
andر
was down on the 24th night
so in this nar
the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
theران was on 24th night ofضان
اللهمضان
[Silence]
ليله القدر
that 10
right so 21 23 25 27 29
are
for
our misunding of this
actions during the last 10 of a lot of
people will kind of squand or lax during
the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ليله القدر
with respect
‏what
me if we
to what is
the 21 23 25 27 29 if we were to
‏would
2 24 26 28 30
الاواخر
ليله القدران
القدر
because
‏be on the nights with respect to what
is so if the month is 30 days long it
will be the 21 or the 23d or the 25th or
the 27th or 29th but if the month
happens to be 29 days is will be with
respect to what
as the schar mentioned and so
in the opinion of the maority of the
schar
‏ange
restrict
could any
of the propet
when he said وانزل القران
في الرابع او 24
من رمضان
قران
24م
[Silence]
ليله القدر الله سبحانه وتعالى
انا انزلناه في ليله القدر انا انزلناه في
ليله مباركه
سبحانه وتعالى
واثله بنق
رمضان
اقرا بسم ربك الذي خلق 16
was 24th
عليه السلام
صلى الله عليه وسلم
first
wasied was up was
before
the eloquence yet the divine truth
صلى الله عليه وسلم
انسوا عائشه رضي الله عنها ساد فرجع بها
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يرجف فؤاده
صلى الله عليه
‏andوني
زملوني
التزميل
زملوني وصبوا علي من
‏me and some
cover me andold
at the time thiser
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فلما
قالت عائشه
واخبرها الخبر
يعني اخبر خديجه بما حدث
قال لقد خشيت على نفسي
زملوني
بالجمع
وقالت
بعد ما زلموه
قالural
was there more personوني
customs in the culture the time of the
propetai
was
it was a very modest cultur what do we
mean by a modest culture
modest in the sense that you would not
mention a man's wife
even by
اهلك بالجمع
‏would not
this was to overing
right because
that is unned and crosses
and so when
the prophet
was
‏gather
he say in inural
cover me and speaking to aural
when they covered him speaking about
the only people in the house him and
however in the
culture at that time
was of such
‏becauseen
ifing
my
one
will into the mind of man who is
listening to me and that's inappropriate
I wouldn't have anyone thinking about my
wife I would say my family right
‏no
un intendy
would minden
this is how
was
her
said
he said feared for
‏could some
‏I was going to die
because
والله
said
if was death
الله
لقد خشيت على نفسي يعني خشيت ان اكون قد
مسست في عقلي كانه يقول صلى الله عليه
‏insanity insan maning
that could
hum
لا يخزيك الله ابدا
الله
فانك لتصل الرحم
وتحمل الكل
وتكسب المعدوم
وتقري الضيف
وتعين على نوائب الحق
‏byى
because of
numberصل
الرحم
وتحمل الكل
هو الثقل
تحمله يعني تجد احدا من الناس مكلولا
مضغوطا من الثقل من هم او دين او ما شابه
ذلك فتحمل عنه
وتكسب المعدومه
وفي روايه وتكسب المعدومه
وتكسب المعدوم
وتكسب المعدومه
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وتقري الضيف تقري تقري
وتكرم
وتقري الضيف يعني وتكرم الضيف
وتعين على نوائب الحق
all
you are
uningalty
are
mentioned asidence
صلى الله عليه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان شاء الله تعالى نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان ينفعني واياكم
بالقران العظيم وان يبارك لي ولكم فيه من
الايات والذكر الحكيم بما فيه من الايات
والذكر الحكيم والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين